as peças 10 e 11 mil doentes última
semana por isso não possíveis mas depois
não só conectar o meu pulmão ver todos
vocês vêem não mas aqui dentro do meu
pulmão tem umas coisas brancas que teve
infecção especulação em linguagem medo e
30 com muito toque com muito calor e o
pessoal aqui em casa tudo com está o
ambiental caso do ronaldo atual indo
agora também o bpi também doem melhor já
consegue falar hoje então só vamos fazer
o nosso brilho do ei não falei com ele
mas não tem vivido três padrinhos eu
tinha de cumprir um desafio porque o
caso de ganho mais dinheiro do que eu
então eu vou tentar ver tinha agora
agora já sei qual é o teu atingiu era
assim mas quando chegaram sem milagres
mirim o dinheiro comprar 400 euros em
junho juntamente com o caso seja
comprava 200 euros e o caso de comprar
200 mil e isso aconteceu e muita
experiência quase 1 5 mil e 2 mil nós
conseguirmos nós vamos comprar e manter
um sistema online em quatro horas bateu
próximas 24 horas sem milagre nós
compramos mil euros ou seja filme euroso
caso imaginam não
o primeiro vai andar no jardim lá e vai
levar cinco pessoas além da mãe ter
menos dinheiro vai andar não podia sim
eu batizei sofre desde o 2º andar aqui
da casa tanto faz um também o vídeo do
caso e você vai ganhar muito pessoal ea
vossa experiência diferente nós
compramos menos mas elas são mais caros
portanto a probabilidade dos seis
prêmios melhor é muito alta e vejam só
meu é muito linda responde mercado muito
em lei nada mais gosta de ginástica
justamente a outra era um euro e essa
custa 10 portanto o mínimo que a equipe
é de geografia kassai hun premiê o
máximo pop e 500 mil euros só uma
resposta ou link do seu meio milhão de
euros número 10 horas para só em 15
milhões bilhetes é de 15 milhões apenas
duas campanhas têm o prêmio de meio
milhão de euros apenas duas brasileiras
brasília que permeou milhão e 2 milhão
no barro é mesmo só na espanha consistem
em que nós temos cinco números aqui em
cima de nós temos duas partes depois
temos um monte de prêmios de que nós
podemos ganhar sofrem nestes prémios
tiveram os mesmos números que em cinzas
mas não vai pode ter uma multiplicação
ou seja labs 10 - mil volts vale dizer
os 10 mil ou seja 10 não pública
essa é nossa primeira só vai dar muita
sorte ou acaso está pronto para a lei
das ghesas para alguns números mas não
tem muito 30 sem muitos trintas ok
pessoal tem de 34 16 3632 sair em cima e
embaixo nós já temos um prémio garantido
para iago imagina que ganhou a primeira
edição 2011 2024
imaginem 81mm sol o prêmio seria 100
euros
assim em 1139 também não tem 18
3432 3331 3933 2140 22 25 18
gosto que é um pai
publicado a 29 36 não tem meu de 88 aqui
1323 1923
não tenho é tudo maior estrela 23 21
há ainda 38 e 21 14 13 21 para 28 3
eu ganhe 30 euros até agora embora
próxima de 191 e 25
nós somos da sorte as peças devem ter pb
3433 daí não tem há como não tem com 16
40 e 29 26 de aluno não tem bosta
nenhuma 24 20 39 21 36 uma mãe 3124 e
não tem nada meu 2219 ou não tem nada
que ele não tem nada como é que 32 meu é
tudo ao lado
imagine que o prêmio era 30 mil euroso
estava aqui editar o vídeo eo para que
esta parte tem estado muito chata porque
porque nós não ganhamos nada não é muito
fácil ganhar com essas casas poderiam
abrir aí umas 10 tem prêmio portanto vou
contar esta partida caiu só deixar as
partes bom pelo prêmio assim acho que
foi mais importante porque vocês não
querem ver outras para ir para o deserto
eu acho que é mesmo possível então só
deixar as partes emprego e não só para o
biguá
88 boa 3484 tinha 42 da casa da bruxa
ela quem joguei me deu mais do que a
última estrela com o pé e deixou muita
falta agora um momento crítico
a festa que já faz 50 65 85 95 ou seja 4
por aí
o dinheiro que eu gostaria é bom só
passei lá no canal no caso em que eu vá
fazer ajuste de nível e vamos ver quem
vai ganhar já sabem quem perder vai
andar nu pelo jardim o batismo é só quem
sabe você tá aqui ó 100 mil likes me
instruiu para comprarmos mil euros na
linha que só fiquem bem até a próxima